you say kikuchi is up on the hill for
manager scott service you say has seen
his fastball velo drop a little bit his
last couple of starts here we go you say
is ready stepping in to lay things off
for the athletics mark canna here's the
wind-up high leg kick hesitates delivers
and it's strike three called on the
inside corner with a cutter
he gets kenna looking at strike three
and right away there's strikeout number
one for you say kikuchi and frankie
montas for bob melvin and the oakland
athletics for montas a 4.33 era so far
this season two outbound over the first
nothing nothing and here's kyle seeger a
left-handed hitter 216.
here's the 3-2 to seeger now by montas
in secrets the ground ball to the right
side right into the ship jacob wilson at
second is there fires to first with the
out and montas has a one two three
bottom of the first and after one the
a's and the mariners no score designated
hitter jed lowry will lead things off
here in the top of the second for the
a's here's the one two on the way swing
and a miss and a fast ball for strike
three
lowry strikes out of that is strikeout
number two for you say kikuchi
here he is cal raleigh switch any
catcher
batting 125 but only 16 at bats out of
the air a couple of days ago and
colorado got his first major league hit
and his first two major league runs
batted in with a line shot double in the
gap in right center he was called up
right
at the very end of the first half of the
season right before the all-star break
now the stretch
and the 1-0 pitch on the way to cal
swinging a fly ball deep to right field
cal raleigh with his first major league
home run goodbye baseball
raleigh with a two-run shot way back
into the lower deck and right here at
t-mobile park and the mariners have a
two-nothing lead way to go kid number
one
in the big leagues his first major
league home run
jumping on a one-o pitch from frankie
montas and raleigh put it into orphan
how about that there's luis terence has
been swinging a hotbed since june 15th
and
keeping him in the lineup
got a four game hitting straight four
for his last 11.
here's the next offer to torrence
swinging a drive deep in the right field
in the corner piscotty going back leaps
up on goodbye baseball
back to back home runs by cal raleigh
and luis terence to rams going the other
way he tucks it inside the right field
foul pole
holy smokes his 12th home run of the
season his 10th since his return from
triple-a tacoma
back-to-back home runs and the mariners
now lead the a's three to nothing here
in the bottom of the second
wow
so chapman at the plate against kikuchi
he awaits the 1-0 cacucci readies and
delivers and a fastball stroke toward
right center field on the run is bowers
in the alley and it's gone
matt chapman drives one to right center
his 12th of the year gets the a's on the
board
and they trailed 3-1 3-1 seattle olson
saw one pitch and hit it back to the
mound for a 1-6-3 double play in the
first
and that one's hit deep to right field
and
that baby's goal olson with number 26 on
the year as he gets one down and in from
kikuchi 02 and launches it into the
seats and the ace now trail 3-2
there is cannon struck out twice
that one is light left field headed for
the corner jacob wilson rounds second
jacob wilson goes to third he's being
waved home here comes the throw to the
plate and it bounces away from the
catcher wilson scores and this game is
tied at three
and the battery is elvis andrews the
look in by usa
here's the stretch and the 2-2 pitch
swing and a miss for strike three and
that is strikeout number 10 for you say
kikuchi and the a's leave the go ahead
run stranded over at third base but the
a's gonna run to tie it up two outs
nobody on top of the sixth
here is laureano
gucci sets
now fires home
swing at a miss strike three he rips
another change up off the plate to
l'oreal his 12th strikeout tonight you
say
a career-best dozen punch-outs this
evening against the athletics
to the bottom of the sixth tied at three
cal raleigh
who has homered and struck out
now the pause at the belt the turn here
it is swung out of miss on a splitter
down good job by moan toss works out of
trouble france left at second
and keeps the game tied after six
the a's three and the mariners three
now the bases are loaded for elvis
andrews seawall stands beneath the chin
fires home
swing and a miss the slider gets the
veteran elvis andrews and paul seawall
escapes the flames in the top of the
seventh and he leaves them loaded here
comes shenlong jr
let's see if shed gets geared up for
that fastball the 3-0
fastball kicks away from murphy to the
backstop here comes dylan moore he
tiptoes home across home plate and the
mariners have taken the lead
it's 4-3 with two outs in the bottom of
the seven j.p crawford at the plate
who's over three
in field back
and a 3-2 pitch to crawford
swinging a foul tip murphy holds on and
the inning is over but
the mariners with two outs strike on
back-to-back wild pitches
and work to do for the a's on to the
eighth they trail 4-3
so two out second and third luis
torrance will check in
torrance has homeward he's fly to center
and bounced out
hannigan's at third seeger is at second
they lead from second and third here's
the delivery now to torrens and he
swings in lines one caught by elvis at
short and petite works out of it and
keeps the is down by just a long run
seattle leaves runners at second and
third we go to the ninth and it's four
three
and now the a's are down to their final
out and here comes pesky tony kemp
champ in the lead he goes 3-2 pitch
swing and a miss strike 3 and the ball
game is over the mariners win it a final
score of four to three in the series
tied at 1-1 and the mariners have just
handed skipper scott's service his 400th
career win
and right now the mariners are three and
a half back of the oakland a's in the
wild card race and folks this was a
dandy of a ball game here at the corner
of edgar and dave at t-mobile park
kendall graveman striking out tony kemp
for the final out of the ball game and
graveman picks up save number 10 on the
year